well making numbers start number 15 for
the reds he's this is start number 264
in his major league career through a lot
of different ball clubs and i'll tell
you what players love to play behind him
because he's got a very quick pace
between pitches he pitches with a lot of
feel keeps the ball in the yard one of
the things that tough to do and you're
only topping out around 90 miles an hour
but the two guys in this lineup that
have given him problems are contreras
who by the way is batting in the leadoff
spot and chris bryant who gives
everybody on the red staff a lot of
problems one away in the first with a
man on the batter is anthony rizzo
base hit
runners at first and second down
bobby two for 16 in his career against
miley
is just going to get through
and coming home
is chris bryant and baez delivers one
nothing comes
two on one out and here is patrick
wisdom first pitch sharp ground ball
nice backhand pick by suarez throw to
india one on the first and top double
play
oh they needed that and geno delivers
with the backhand pick and foul ground
kyle hendricks he is the starting
pitcher for the cubs this afternoon
check in with the professor and his
arsenal sinker 86 87 miles per hour
they'll elevate a four-seamer from time
to time change up gets a lot of ground
balls and swings and misses and he's
just as curveball
15 of the time
and got india to chase strikeout out
number one back-to-back singles by
castillanos and vato and the batter's
tyler naquin
and strike three good work kyle
hendricks
a
professorial pitch one down and the
batter now is jake mariznick marissa
drives one in the air right center on
the run is nate when the center feeler
can't get it that balls up against the
wall
racing around second marisnick with
those long strides motoring into third
with a standing triple
two outs and a man at third kyle
hendricks the batter
bouncer up the middle and through for an
rvi and a two-nothing lead
how about that kyle hendricks
how about that indeed the little nine
hopper right through the middle of the
infield gets the job done we go to the
bottom of the second inning kyle
hendricks to face suarez
swinging a ground ball to third
backhanded by wisdom long throw and
that's going to be
in time good play patrick wisdom at
third base he took a base hit away from
a eugenio suarez well wisdom got one
taken away from him in his first debate
and it was a double play and then he
returned a favor to suarez now tucker
barnhart after farmer ties josh harrison
for the national league lead in times
hit by pitch
opposite way to left
half retreat spun around he won't get it
off the wall former steams up to third
furious wave is on he races to the plate
throw in
no chance safe slide on the left hip
from farmer barnhart to second red's on
the board 2-1 miley hitting 182 this
season he hits a little looper shallow
left coming in making a diving catches
hat for out number two he was playing
shallow he got a good jump on the ball
came in and made a sprawling catch in
shallow left two down two down here in
the third joey vado who's singled in the
opening inning
a high pop
short left
and
half has it bono out number three we
have completed three on the fourth of
july from great american ball park
corner just back on the active roster
after having a hamstring strain that had
him out since the 26th of may
hot shot to third another spectacular
play by suarez are you kidding me
and motto cleans it up with the swipe at
first
well that's the second ball that nico
horner tried on geno suarez and it's
just not gonna get past him buddy
grounded to miley athletic lead feeds in
stride india on the first double play
one four three hey eugenio suarez the
batter
and that is the fourth strikeout for
kyle hendricks by the way now the lineup
flips over to wilson contreras
plops on down to left center there's the
speed contreras turns it on naquin
challenged one hop thrown a second there
in time terrible ugly slide right into a
tag india nails him at the back here's
the pitch to rizzo swing gonna miss down
on strikes rizzo and the inning is over
and the reds have two on with one out
and jesse winker coming to the plate
a shot
horner they get one
they get two what a double play
big pitch from hendricks and horner was
all over it nico horner at the plate who
was twice grounded out to third base
and miley gets him swinging steady died
of off-speed stuff and that is bad
mariznick has a couple of hits today he
tripled and scored in the second inning
he's singled in the fourth
broken back fair ball
suarez makes the throw there mariznick
sprinting down the strike fun battle
between these two guys and figure out
what hendricks is going to throw and
what vato is looking for
hits that high
deep mariznick back at the track and
hauls it in
wow nothing for joey two down and the
batter now is tyler nate one doesn't get
it and
that's out number three big spot facing
chris bryant anthony rizzo on deck man
on two down
grounded india backhand long throw to
first on a bounce motto picks it clean
base is loaded here in the bottom of the
seventh with nobody out tyler stevenson
is going to be a pinch batter
coming home wisdom they get one
contreras holds
on the stevenson bounce out
jonathan indy a one for three bases
and the reds loaded the game a bases
loaded bruise
former comes home even at two
he inherits bases loaded left on left
poised to face the all-star jesse
broken back right side
one out and that's all freeman scores
reds claim their first lead of the game
three to two runners at first and third
two down and now nick castellanos
and got him swinging out of trouble but
not before the reds break through
to get to
garrett's 3-2
a swing and a base hit into left field
stopping at second is half sogar
punching one past the third baseman
suarez and the cubs now have two men on
with only one away in the ninth inning
so two on one out tying run now and
scoring position at second base and back
to the top of the order and here is
wilson contreras 0-2
grounded suarez
second one
double play
a clean sweep